uh let's just jump to the first story
man this story is this is nuts
i was sitting on my couch and i saw a
tweet brandon strzok
who's been on the show several times has
been arrested by the fbi
we have this local news outlet ketv 7
omaha says
omaha fbi agents arrest founder of walk
away campaign
for actions during u.s capital attack
they say brandon strzok 44 was arrested
monday by agents from the fbi omaha
field office
strzok faces charges of impeding a law
enforcement officer during civil
disorder knowingly entering and
remaining on restricted grounds without
lawful authority
and or engaging in disorderly conduct
within proximity to a restricted
building
to impede official functions and
engaging in disorderly conduct with
intent to disturb a hearing before
congress
court documents show that officials were
tipped off about strzok posting a video
near the capitol entrance shouting go
go the video was later removed and
officials said they could not find any
video or posts on his twitter page
relating to his actions the capital
however the fbi was sent multiple
screenshots
these screenshots reportedly revealed
that strzok made the following comments
on twitter saying
quote patriots at the capitol hold the
line
quote i arrived at the capitol a few
hours ago as patriots were storming from
all sides
i was quite close to entering myself as
police began tear gassing us from the
door
i inhaled tear gas and got in my eyes
patriots began exiting shortly after
saying congress had been cleared
he goes on to say he was confused for
six to eight weeks everybody on the
right was saying 1776
and that if congress moves forward it
will mean a revolution so congress moves
forward
patriots storm the capital now everyone
is virtue signaling their embarrassment
that this happened
i think that quote right there is a
really good example of what happens when
you're in an echo chamber
as if anybody thought that going inside
a building and physically standing there
was going to change the government
overnight just
definitely not the case but the more
important points i'll make right here
they say according to documents one
video showed an officer from the u.s
capitol police holding a protective
shield
as individuals pushed past the officer
toward the entrance of the u.s capitol
the officer held his shield up in the
air the report states
according to documents strzok is heard
shouting take it away from him
and others in the crowd then yelled take
the shield as several people in the
crowd grabbed the officer's shield
strzok yelled
take it take it officials learn that
strzok was a self-described former
liberal
and the founder of the walk away
campaign
now here's where it gets crazy i've got
here the fbi affidavit
they say the fbi received multiple tips
referencing the video of strzok at the
us capital
including a tip from witness one i
interviewed witness one on january
13th witness one stated he she was a
relative
of strzok now everything else we've
heard for the most part
accusations were made videos were sent
and i'll also point out this is probably
why facebook banned walk away and all of
the people
involved see we didn't i don't think any
of us actually saw those videos unless
you had been following walk away i
wasn't
so when i heard that they banned the
entirety of walk away i was like whoa
that's
nuts now if they're saying he was
posting these videos of himself storming
the capital it's not surprising at all
but i think the bigger the bigger issue
here is for one we got the news that's
it
founder of walk away arrested relative
turn them in
i mean play stupid games win stupid
prizes so i don't know why anyone went
near this mess at the capitol they were
never going to accomplish anything
they were never going to stop the
certification of the vote i mean
that ship sailed a long time ago for a
few hours they did
they delayed the inevitable at a big
cost to them personally so
wait wait i disagree that that shaman
who believed he was an alien he was
definitely a threat to national security
and he he he became very close to being
the speaker of the house
i mean how can you argue against that
well it was the insurrection wait wait
wait wait
he was standing in mike pence's place
yes for the for the president of the
senate
that that legally means he was the
president
right that's that's the idea isn't it by
physically going in there and standing
there you you hold the title that's the
rules right well that's what
is that what people thought was going to
happen but okay look look look sorry for
interrupting
your point but i was saying like it is
disturbing to see people starting to
turn in family members it'd be one thing
right if it was
there was another story that you and i
were talking about before we went live
right where
there's a threat of like imminent
violence or terrorism but like just
snitching on your family members
there's got to be some really extreme
circumstances to justify anything close
to that
and just posts that you saw from them on
twitter i would never do that personally
well we also have to understand we're in
a political climate where it seems like
the fbi has been absolutely
activated previously before when it when
it came to other issues the fbi is kind
of sitting around but now
i mean they're putting up bulletin
boards they're putting up uh
wanted posters they're putting up tip uh
hotlines it looks like they finally you
know got off of their buttocks and
started being extremely proactive and
very efficient at their job
when previously with other cases like
the epstein case they kind of didn't
really do much
not just not just that case here's the
thing there's no no trust me there's a
long piece
of the fbi not doing their job correctly
anybody who actually committed crimes at
the capitol they should be doing that
right
but where was that during the blm riots
this summer right they weren't tracking
down every person
but don't smash the window brad those
were peaceful
mostly peaceful and they stopped and
they bought covid
according to scientific studies that
were released and published by cnn news
are you telling me cnu
cnn news is lying and you're cutting me
down i'm telling you i'm gonna have to
speak louder
tim okay sorry go ahead oh no
i'm just telling you though when they
when they tell you it's mostly peaceful
with the burning background
with the building on fire it might not
actually be mostly peaceful
this is a serious a serious problem man
uh i've had emails from people saying
like
tim you talk about the same thing over
and over again just different times like
same
same stuff different day we don't swear
on the show and i'm like what do you
want me to do
like i'm telling you it's happening it's
happening i what i won't do is be like
oh i am i'm absolutely shocked by this
double standard
the fbi arresting these insurrectionists
and
we have antifa still riding now like
they've never stopped they're
crazy but look look i know you guys want
to rag on the fbi and all that
but i i got to point out the family
thing because you brought up that story
of the kid and his dad right
let me tell you how insane and
despicable things are getting we have a
story from the new york times
son tipped off fbi about his father who
was in who who is charged in capital
riot
he says i put my emotions behind me to
do what i thought was right
and you know what he thought was right
in his twitter on his twitter account
his his official link you know on
twitter you edit your profile you can
put a link
this is linked to a gofundme this
morning this morning
his gofundme was at like 90 something
thousand dollars
and i was just like dude it's one thing
to rat your family out
maybe you have to do it if there's a
real threat maybe you have to right it's
true
it's not it's not so simple it's another
thing to be like guys i turned my dad
and here's my gofundme
i'm looking for a hundred thousand
dollars and wait since then he's raised
another about 25 grand
so he increased the total goal to 200
thousand he's calling it his college
fund
listen god this guy reported his dead
weeks ago
because his dad was saying he was going
to do something big and i'm like
look if your dad or your family member
was antifa
and they were talking about doing
something big especially when you have
stories of all these riots going on
and you turn them in i get it it's it
sucks
okay but then if you come out publicly
and you're like i'd like to do an
interview with with cnn in the new york
times and then publish a gofundme to
make hundreds of thousands of dollars
it's horrible wow dude well yeah you
brought up a very important point
because
it could have been a scenario where
there was a present danger
and at that time you know we don't know
the interpersonal relationship we don't
know if there was abuse we don't know
any of this stuff
but at the same time one thing we have
to note here the mainstream media
especially cnn
they're taking this case and they're
running with it they're running
you know until the cows come home
essentially exploiting this and and
and loving it and and they're running
with it as as a headline
story and this is where he even wrote in
his own description he's like
i'm getting so much support after my cnn
interview
i might not have a home to live in but
but it seems like he's
getting something home now that's the
most dysfunctional incentive structure
though you're setting up with these like
resist
bucks i mean this is what they did with
claudia conway right that she was
willing to drag her dad on
her mom rather on twitter for working
for the president and so like the new
york times had a glowing profile of her
and they started
constantly sharing her and promoting her
and turning her into a tick-tock star
and it's like i don't think we should be
incentivizing with money
young people to do this kind of thing
and sell out their family
unless you're a kami and you want the
culture evolution then you're then
you're cheering and jumping up and down
and clapping for it happy
but wait i thought they didn't believe
in incentivizing people with money
that's the funny thing i said
you know that's what i was saying
earlier that it's a lot of people claim
to be socialists or leftists but when it
comes down to it they're the
worst version of capitalists everything
they complain about capitalism like the
raw exploitation for money i'm like what
do you think it is you're doing
when you literally sell your dad to the
state for money
that's incredible look if i had to
report a family member i'd be
embarrassed i'd be i'd be saddened
but more importantly what if it was
possible he could have talked to his dad
what if when he heard his dad say crazy
stuff he was like yo dad sit down let me
talk to you
like we need to have a family
intervention about this because saying
i'm gonna do something big just you wait
what does that really mean it's crazy is
that is that when you're like well
something big time to call the feds
did he say it to the kid or did he write
it on twitter well well
later afterwards he told the kid he
would shoot him
so but that he reported he poured his
dead weeks ago
he too so the dad told this kid that he
was at the capitol
and if he snitched on him he would do
you know what you know what traders
deserve and traders get [ __ ] oh well
this sick guy sounds unstable totally i
think the kid's in the right here
well so his kid reported him weeks ago
all right and that's what
that's what i was saying a lot of people
are immediately jumping the gun saying
oh don't ret on your family that's
messed up and i'm like i don't know your
dad's saying like
no that's fine it's the fundraising part
that's right
is he so the kid's like homeless now is
did he lose his last parent no i don't
think so
well he he wrote in his i might be
kicked out of my house due to my
involvement yeah
i might be that's funny dude i got
sympathy for that guy that that kid
because that's a weird if your dad
threatens to shoot you and goes and does
some
illegal act that oh absolutely you have
to distance yourself from your family
when you're
younger than 18 is he imagine well it
could go either way we don't know his
future could be shattered we don't know
what happened personally between
these two individuals and their personal
relationship it could be that he was
making an off-handed
joke and wasn't that serious about it it
could be that he could be an abusing
father that beat his children
and literally threatened more harm on
them yeah you know so we don't know
exactly what happened there but again
it's the fundraising check this out on
his gofundme he keeps saying like
i'm raising let me see let me see what
wow he goes i'm raising the goal to 100
000 from requests and it's staying at
100 000.
thank you everyone for your messages
they all have been read and cherished
thank you
people have requested again that i moved
the goal post once more
i'm sorry about saying it saying it
would stay but you guys have been
persistent so i gotta ask for more money
i guess i gotta
take more money there's one more i move
the goal post
once more people have been requesting
it's just listen
it's not me asking for the money
increasing the goal it's that people
keep saying dude we want to give you
money
you don't need to increase the goal to
make money if your goal is five grand
people can still keep donating
increasing the goal has the purpose of
making people think you haven't reached
your goal yet so they're more likely to
donate
i doubt well no look there probably are
people saying like hey increase it right
and he's like i guess okay but just from
a raw perspective you kind of have to
respect the hustle
yeah totally he's a capitalist and and
you know
i'll be completely honest the money he's
taking this is this is a really funny
question when it comes to money people
are like
you're getting paid by you know soros or
like the koch brothers or whatever and
i'm kind of like
who would you rather have the money the
good brothers are me
like i kind of isn't it a good thing
that these organizations lose money
giving it away to other people
they they lose that power yeah we don't
you're kind of paid by the koch brothers
no the point i'm making is i don't know
what this dude's politics are
he's probably not particularly political
but he's now taken 125 grand from
you know establishment and tribalist
lefties so it's like i guess better he
has the money and spends it on whatever
he wants to than a bunch of you know
crazy people like it's better than mitch
mcconnell taking 150
000 from the nra probably because it's
like grassroots at least
wait what like we're talking about
people donating money and receiving
money like
these politicians that are getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
corporations
we don't sit here and talk and complain
about each of those but it's probably
way worse than a kid
going on gofundme and taking like this
what i'm saying is this kid's probably
gonna like buy a car
and then just like go drive around and
do nothing with my crypto but the people
who have the money in the first place
are gonna be like promoting
fringe political causes and stuff so
it's like you know i guess
he takes the money and he just like you
know goes to school with it i guess
he's influencing one person he's paying
them to influence him instead of paying
to influence others you know what i mean
but it does incentivize more of this
right that's that's the main issue
that's why right if he gets it out then
a
bunch of other kids out there whose
parents maybe are not that crazy
are going to see the money and maybe the
next one i mean i'll give this guy the
full benefit of that maybe his dad was
crazy maybe
he had to do this right but there's
probably some kids out there who look at
that and are like
i want to get a slice of that and maybe
they will not be telling the truth when
they do it
yo the chick who turned in her mom
uh let's hold on wait is this the same
one
oh there's many there's many of them
that's that's the thing
this didn't try once it happened a
couple times and
you as you said you could only imagine
if you know your dad says eat your
vegetables
your kid's going to look back at them
like i could call the fbi
buttocks right now fool the nazis and
the
communists the russian communist soviets
would would be like
turn them in do the right thing or maybe
or
through threat of force and now they're
doing it through bribery it's this new
world order
check it out the other the young woman
who turned her mother in
has raised 73 391 dollars
of her now 150 000 goal and of course
she's going pay for
college uh-huh well well to be fair
biden's going to take a lot of that
money with his new tax plan
oh and and then college i mean well
they're going to get their student loans
off cancer
anyway i'm going to tell you my hard
prediction i think these two people are
gonna go to jail
or uh well kids yeah yeah yeah maybe
maybe not jail maybe it's a little harsh
i think because what people don't
realize i've heard this story a lot
when people get an internet windfall and
they think the money is free and they
don't pay taxes on it
and the irs comes in knocking and they
end up owing the irs a ton of money so
this dude who's getting
all of this money for college could be
argued that
by putting that so i'm not a tax lawyer
but you know what i've been advised is
if you want to give someone a gift then
there can be no consideration
consideration being a contractual term a
legal term
so if i said like here you are luke one
gorilla
for free and you can do whatever you
want with it then
that's a gift but if i say this gorilla
is 4x
it's no longer a gift it depends though
you could argue that paying someone's
medical bills or college could
constitute a gift
but we saw this i don't know if you guys
remember when occupy organized that big
debt payoff
where they were like buying people's
medical debt people were getting tax
bills because of it because paying off
someone's debt is giving them money
and then depending on what the money was
for if there was consideration involved
like
i'm gonna give you money but can only be
used for this then the person has to pay
taxes on it
a gift can have no strings attached well
right now with kovit people are getting
tax bills for their stimulus checks and
their expanded unemployment benefits
that's crazy unemployment is a tax you
pay
unemployment tax to cover the
unemployment then they pay it out to you
but then they tax it
yeah so it's it's already a tax when you
spend it you pay sales tax to earn it
you pay income tax
to just keep your property you pay
property tax that i mean it's
multiplied a million times over at the
at the gun store where you went to
on the receipt when it said taxes it
said taxation is theft
yeah so i mean there's local businesses
that
are hit either way i mean you brought up
an important point i mean they tax
almost
there's so many aspects of life are
taxed you receive money you
you get taxed you spend money you get
taxed and then you got to pay taxes on
top of those taxes
on top of other taxes that's just this
is but hold on
this is why what a lot of these lefties
understand is that lowering the tax rate
can actually increase tax revenue oh
yeah
because if the dollar if if i have one
dollar and we we spread it around this
table
by the time the dollar is done being
traded the government has all of it
all of it but if you raise the taxes to
a point where i can't even afford to
spend it then i just hold the dollar
well and also none of it high taxes
discourage economic activity right if
the top
rate is 90 like aoc's dream right people
aren't going to work
to earn those extra dollars once they
hit that bracket then there's less
overall revenue from that too
i disagree um you're you're right but
they just do clever it's it's a rich
people's game
once they get to that point they're just
like they just buy other things that
that don't get taxed they just open up a
charity
and that's one of the biggest scams out
there just like bill gates who said he's
going to give all of his money
away to charity and then tripled his
wealth somehow in those panama
trippers didn't get enough attention did
you guys pay attention to those when
they dropped the package yeah
the person who leaked it died or
something oh my god i don't know but all
these really wealthy people
have bank accounts and celebrities or
they're about i know one of putin's best
friends has tons of money there he's
like the musician guy
i mean that's we that's like the
elephant in the room
it with this economy right so it's rich
people
have the means and the ability and the
legal power and they get away with
you're like
are you like a tax lawyer no no not a
lawyer but no but i do
i report on economics and write about
economics and that's been one of the
most interesting things about covet and
the big response like the federal
reserve
printed trillions of dollars essentially
a lot of it went to big corporations
a lot of the paycheck protection program
which was supposed to help small
businesses
went to big corporations this is this
happens all the time with government
this is why the swamp is actually one of
the truest things trump ever said
right in washington even the progressive
legislators
legislators get called by all the big
companies every day and get tons of
money from them
and make sure that the big bill doesn't
hurt their bottom line it's all
like that there's a study where they say
something like
public opinion has zero impact on public
policy
and the opinions of major corporations
and the wealthy
impacts almost exclusively makes sense
why why is a politician gonna be worried
about well i think the internet has
changed things though
because it used to be that you needed
the money to get to run the ads
now it's it's the twitter game it's you
know aoc goes on twitter and she starts
ranting about the republicans and like
how they're evil
and stuff like that and then she gets
more and more followers and they just
people love to hate they love to be
angry
you know they want to feel their anger
as justified
well that's the impulse that gathers
your attention
the most so there have been many
clinical studies and if you could make
someone
fearful and scared those are the
incentives to make people click more
than anything else out there in the
internet and
a lot of these news companies a lot of
these big tech companies know this and
they
they need to keep people on their
platforms they need to keep people
uh you know engaged as much as they can
so they so they hit
this fear uh what is it uh what is it
flight
fighter flight fighter flight instincts
all the time and our
emotional systems are hyperbolically
just going insane
after being induced into so much of this
kind of casino gamified
informational warfare that's blasted in
your face thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you